players took the field tonight at
Centennial High School to commemorate
the life of a teen who died during a
flag football game ashari Hughes died
January 5th of a heart condition tonight
was the first game for both Centennial
and Desert Oasis High School since she
passed before the game the Las Vegas
Raiders joined both schools for what was
a special ceremony ashari's parents say
they couldn't have been more proud
no be carried on in this way and people
reflect her in such a positive way
because she was such a positive kid the
impact is huge we've had several vigils
in ashari's honor both here and at
Desert Oasis and the outpouring of love
that we've had since her passing has
just been amazing both teams wore
ashari's Jersey during the game and each
team received a football from Raiders
Alum Roy Hart with a personal message
saying do it for ashari